[Musique]
nous nous voulons reprendre l'argent des
européens pour le mettre au service du
développement des services publics
on vit dans un continent européen où il
ya énormément de richesses mais elles
sont confisquées aux habitants aux
populations elles servent les les
grandes multinationales on a fait de
l'europe un grand marché pour les plus
grands groupes les plus puissants qui
puise nos ressources qui ne payent pas
d'impôts alors que nous avons besoin
partout de moyens l'union européenne est
évidemment beaucoup trop libérale elle a
été conçue sur le modèle qui a conduit à
la grande crise financière capitaliste
de 2008 il faut changer d'orientation il
ne faut pas quitter l'union européenne
c'est l'endroit où nous avons nous
vivons nous avons besoin de relations
avec nos voisins on voit bien avec le
break site que ça ne mène à rien à part
au chaos politique
donc il faut changer l'union européenne
parce que si elle reste sur cette
orientation actuelle
là elle risque de disparaître parce que
les peuples ne veulent plus de cette
union européenne lag l'union européenne
de la concurrence et de l'argent ils
veulent une europe qui soit une europe
où opèrent en respectant les peuples les
nations et en respectant le travail ça
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
[Musique]
puisqu'il va y avoir des élections
européennes déjà en élisant des députés
qui ont envie de la changer et pas en
envoyant en parlement européen soit des
représentants de maquereaux soit des
représentants de marine le pen qui vont
s'allier à toutes les extrêmes droites
européennes pour jeter l'europe demain
dans la guerre et dans le racisme
donc il faut élire notamment des députés
communistes parce que nous sommes depuis
le départ des artisans de cette bataille
nous n'avons jamais accepté les traiter
tous n'en avons voté aucun les traités
ultralibéraux qui font la loi de l'union
européenne actuelle il faut donc élire
ses députés là et avec eux mené des
combats pour la défense des services
publics pour des grands projets
européens qu'ils soient des projets
sociaux pour créer les conditions d'un
smic européen tirer vers le haut dans
tous les pays de manière à organiser de
la convergence sociale organisée
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans l'union européenne ya beaucoup de
beaux projets européens à mener
p
[Musique]